♪ ♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
BACK ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
ATTACKING HIS OPPONENTS AND
CAUSING CONTROVERSY DURING HIS
RALLY IN TULSA.
>> I’VE BEEN WATCHING THE FAKE
NEWS FOR WEEKS NOW AND
EVERYTHING IS NEGATIVE.
DON’T GO, DON’T COME, DON’T DO
ANYTHING TODAY LIKE I’VE NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT.
I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
YOU ARE WARRIORS.
THANK YOU.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT THE LEADER OF
THIS PARTY.
JOE BIDEN IS THE HELPLESS PUPPET
OF THE RADICAL LEFT.
WHEN YOU DO TESTING TO THAT
EXTENT, YOU ARE GOING TO FIND
MORE PEOPLE, YOU ARE GOING TO
FIND MORE CASES.
SO I SAID TO MY PEOPLE, "SLOW
THE TESTING DOWN, PLEASE."
>> Dana: A SMALLER THAN
EXPECTED CROWD SIZE.
KATIE, I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS HAPPENING WITH THE
OVERPROMISING, UNDER DELIVERING
ON THE CROWD SIZE IS THAT IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR A METRIC TO SHOW THAT THEY
ARE BETTER THAN JOE BIDEN.
SO, THE FUND-RAISING, THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN DOES IT A LITTLE BIT
BETTER.
THE POLL NUMBERS, THEY DO IT A
LITTLE BETTER.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THE ENTHUSIASM
GAP BEEN BETWEEN TRUMP AND BIDEN
IS QUITE LARGE.
THEY ARE VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
DOING SO.
I KNOW ARIZONA IS YOUR HOMETOWN.
WHAT DID THEY LEARN FROM THE
TALLTULSA EXPERIENCE?
>> Katie: I WOULD SAY TO
VERIFY THE NUMBERS OF TICKET
SALES OF WHO IS GOING TO SHOW UP
UP.
THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN AND THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE RIFF ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN THAT SOMEHOW
IS A FAILURE BECAUSE FOLKS ONLY
6,000 PEOPLE SHOWED UP TO THE
FIRST RALLY IN MONTHS DURING THE
END OF A PANDEMIC AND IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THESE RIOTS AND
PROTESTS.
I THINK IT’S A PRETTY SOLID
ARGUMENT TO MAKE, ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THAT JOE BIDEN HAD A
TOWN HALL MEETING WHERE PEOPLE
WERE HANDPICKED.
THERE WERE 20 PEOPLE THERE AND
THERE WASN’T ANY ENTHUSIASM.
MOVING FORWARD, I’M SURE THAT
YOU NOTED, IT WILL NOT BE
OVERPROMISING WHO EXACTLY IS
GOING TO SHOW UP.
YOU JUST DON’T KNOW WHO IS GOING
TO SHOW UP.
BUT THE HISTORY OF THESE RALLIES
IS THAT THERE ARE OVERFLOWING
CROWDS.
I KNOW PEOPLE WHO WAITED IN LINE
FOR HOURS TO GET IN AND NEVER
DID IN PLACES LIKE ARIZONA.
SO I THINK THAT THEY WILL BE
JUST FINE WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING THESE RALLIES BACK ON
THE ROAD.
THE MAJORITY OF LIFE IS SHOWING
UP.
WELL, TRUMP IS SHOWING UP AND
BIDEN IS NOT.
>> Dana: JUAN, THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE EXPLAINED THAT HE
WAS CLEARLY JOKING.
THE WHITE HOUSE REITERATED THAT
TODAY, THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
DECIDED TO TAKE THE BALL AND RUN
WITH IT AND THEY ARE GOING TO
USE THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
PRESIDENT WAS JOKING.
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> Juan: WELL, LET’S JUST TAKE
THE PRESIDENT’S WORD, DANA.
IF HE THINKS THAT’S FUNNY.
I DIDN’T FIND IT FUNNY.
I DON’T THINK MANY PEOPLE FOUND
IT FUNNY.
THE VIRUS IS PRETTY SERIOUS.
EVEN IN PLACES LIKE OKLAHOMA AND
ARIZONA WHERE HE IS GOING NEXT,
WE HAVE SEEN A SPIKE AND
CONTINUATION OF THE PROBLEM.
I THINK THIS WAS AN EPIC
EMBARRASSMENT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO HAS MADE A
BIG, BIG DEAL OUT OF CROWD
SIZES.
AND THE IDEA THAT HIS OWN
CAMPAIGN SAID IT WAS GOING TO BE
A MILLION PLUS AND BUILT THE
STAGE OUT TO HAVE A SECOND
SPEECH FOR THE OVERFLOW.
ALL OF THAT CAME TO NOT.
IT JUST DIDN’T HAPPEN.
AT SOME POINT, YOU HAVE TO TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT’S NOT THE MEDIA, THAT’S THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE OTHER POINT YOU HAVE TO SAY
HERE IS THAT THE POLLS WERE
RIGHT, PICKING UP ON WHAT KATIE
WAS SAYING, IF PEOPLE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT THE VIRUS, IT’S
NOT JUST DEMOCRATS OR THE MEDIA
OR I DON’T KNOW WHO, BUT IN A
DEEP RED STATE LIKE OKLAHOMA,
MAYBE PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THE VIRUS.
MAYBE THAT’S ONE OF THE REASONS
PEOPLE DO NOT COME OUT IN THE
NUMBERS THAT HAD BEEN FORECAST.
BUT OVERALL, I WOULD SAY ON THE
MERITS OF IT, AND THIS GETS TO
WHAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN I HEARD WITH THE PRESIDENT
WAS SAYING, IT JUST STRUCK ME
THAT GOSH, THIS IS LIKE A SUMMER
RERUN.
I’VE SEEN THIS TV SHOW BEFORE.
THERE IS NOTHING NEW HERE.
I’M IN, HE IS NOT RUNNING
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
HE IS RUNNING AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
YOU SAY JOE BIDEN IS A CAPTIVE
OF THE RADICAL LEFT, IT’S KIND
OF WILD.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT HE HAS A
CENTRIST, A MODERATE.
>> Katie: NO, HE’S NOT.
>> Dana: I WANT TO PLAY THE
SOUND FOR YOU OF THE PRESIDENT
TRYING TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
LIGHTER MOMENT ON SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS WE CAN BEFORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I SET I GOT MYSELF A PROBLEM,
GENERAL, BECAUSE I’M WEARING
LEATHER BOTTOM SHOES.
IT WAS LIKE AN ICE SKATING RINK.
IT DOESN’T LOOK GOOD FOR A LONG
TIME FRANKLY, THE TIRE IS NEVER
THE SAME.
THEY GAVE ME THE DISEASE.
>> Dana: DAN, THERE IS
SOMETHING ABOUT A POLITICIAN, NO
MATTER WHO IT IS, IF THEY CAN
HAVE A LIGHTER MOMENT AND MAKE
YOU LAUGH, YOU CAN HIT A
HOME RUN.
>> Dan: YEAH, IT’S A SKILL AND
NOT MANY POLITICIANS ARE GOOD AT
THAT, BECAUSE FOCUS GROUPS TELL
THEM THE STORIES.
TELL THAT STORY.
PEOPLE LAUGH.
IT’S SO WEIRD HE JUST TELLS YOU
THE STORIES THAT ARE IN HIS
HEAD.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS WORN LEATHER
SHOES, IT GOT ME THINKING ABOUT
ICE SKATING RINK’S.
I CAN’T EVEN IMAGINE.
IF I MAY COME BACK FOR A MINUTE,
AN EPIC EMBARRASSMENT?
I MEAN COME ON.
THAT’S A LITTLE HYPERBOLIC TO
SAY THE LEAST.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
VIRAL OUTBREAK.
IF YOU SHOW UP TO A PROTEST,
DON’T WORRY.
YOU ARE A-OK.
THE VIRUS WANT TO ANYTHING TO
YOU.
HE STILL GETS BY SECRET SERVICE
ESTIMATES, BY THE WAY, BETWEEN
TEN AND 12,000 PEOPLE.
I WILL TRUST THEM.
THERE MAY NOT HAVE BEEN TEN OR
12,000, BUT THERE WERE CERTAINLY
10-12000 PEOPLE.
ON MY ESTIMATES, IF JOE BIDEN
HAD AN UNBELIEVABLE 20 PEOPLE IN
HIS RALLY, WHICH KATIE
REFERENCED, WHICH LOOKS LIKE
MAYBE PARCHEESI, THAT MEANS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD 600 MORE
TIMES THAN BIDEN.
IF THIS IS A BINARY CHOICE,
WHICH IT IS ONE, TRUMP, BIDEN,
WOULD YOU WANT TO BE THE?
I WILL TAKE THE TRUMP RALLY ANY
DAY OF THE WEEK.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR.
>> Dana: WE DON’T HAVE TIME
FOR JUAN TO RESPOND, BUT JUST TO
COME AND YOU WERE HERE COVERING
THE SLIDE FOR US.
WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THE WHOLE
EVENT AS A PRESIDENT HEADS TO
ARIZONA LATER THIS WEEK?
>> Jesse: I WILL RESPOND ON
JUAN’S BEHALF.
DANA, YOU ARE RIGHT.
I ADMIT THAT I WAS WRONG.
CROWD SIZES ARE NOW OUR
BAROMETER FOR ENTHUSIASM AND JOE
HAS NO JUICE.
HONESTLY, JOE WOULD KILL FOR
THIS SMALL TRUMP CROWD SIZE.
HE WILL NEVER GET 10,000, AND
NEVER HAS, NEVER WILL.
I THINK HE CRACKS 1,000 ON HIS
MAIN LAUNCH EVENT.
SO PLEASE, JOE CAN’T FILL A
LIBRARY LET ALONE A STADIUM LIKE
THAT.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN TELLING
EVERYBODY HEY, DON’T GO TO THIS
EVENT.
IT’S DANGEROUS.
TO THEJEANETTE THEY HAVE BEEN PA
THEM ON THE BACK FOR BEING SMART
AND HEALTHY?
NO.
DO THINK THEY LOST HIS GAME?
JOE CAN’T EVEN SCORE ONE.
I MEAN, COME ON, THERE’S NOT
EVEN A COMPARISON HERE.
>> Dana: MEANWHILE --